-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody. Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a crowd.
♪♪
Let's get to some news, guys.
We'll get --
The past five days,
President Biden has
been isolating with COVID,
and today, his doctors said
that his symptoms are now
"almost completely resolved."
Yeah, that's correct.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Biden's staff was like,
"Just to be safe,
let's keep him isolated
till 2025."
[ Laughter ]
I'm happy for the president,
because usually when you hear
the words "Biden" and "viral"
it's because he fell
up the stairs. And you go,
"How do you do that?"
Yep, Biden's doctor said
that his pulse, blood pressure,
and respiratory rate
remain absolutely normal.
Then Biden flipped on the news
and his doctor said,
"Never mind."
Biden's been isolating
for the last five days.
When asked how he spent
the time, Biden said,
"I told one story."
[ Laughter ]
A good one. It was a good one.
-Yeah, come on.
-Biden's treatment involves
taking six pills a day
for five days.
All weekend long,
his pill organizer
was holding on for dear life.
It was like...
Pfft! Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
Well, as the ongoing
pilot shortage
leads to more
flight cancellations,
senators have introduced
a new bill
to raise the mandatory
retirement age for pilots.
Yeah, that's who passengers
want flying their plane,
a pilot who thought
his best days are behind him.
He's like, "I'm back,
I'm Maverick."
And you go, "Hold on."
"You're not -- Hold on,
Maverick."
You'll know the pilots are old
when they start showing up
to every flight 3 hours early,
like, "Alright, let's go."
You'll know the pilot's older
when he gets assigned
gate B7 and yells "Bingo."
You know what I'm saying?
And get this, a recent
Alaska Airlines flight
was delayed because two pilots
who were supposed to fly
the plane had "a professional
disagreement."
We actually got a hold
of the pilot's recording.
Listen to this.
-Oh, my God.
It was over peanuts.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, some business news
today --
the barbecue grill company
Weber replaced their CEO
as they continue to struggle
with a decline in sales.
It's not an easy job
because the CEO is annoyed
because another guy was always
standing right behind him,
telling him what to do.
Looks like it's time to flip
those numbers if you want to...
Yeah. Apparently people
aren't excited
to stand in front of a grill
when it's 150 degrees outside.
Listen to this --
due to rising food prices,
burgers and pizzas
are getting smaller.
Yep, a White Castle burger is
now the size of a postage stamp.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously. This is the pizza
I ordered last night.
Look at that thing.
-Oh, my God.
-I actually put the pizza
on top of that little table.
It worked pretty good.
Well, guys,
everyone loves TikTok.
We do love it here,
but sometimes you just want
to skip
the boring parts of the video
and get right
to the good part.
Well, it turns out you can,
alright?
For instance, watching --
if you're watching this video,
you can skip this part.
[ Laughs ]
And go right to this part.
Ooh! Oh! There you go, yup.
[ Laughs ]
"Ooh! Oh!"
Here's a final example.
You can skip this part.
-[ Humming ]
And go right to this part.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some entertainment news, guys --
I saw Disney+
just started streaming
its first R-rated movies.
-Ooh.
-Before this, the only
cursing you heard around Disney+
is when kids
ask their parents to turn on
"Encanto" again.
I'm going to teach you
how to do it now.
Here, just press menu
and then you go to the...
Kid's chewing on
the remote control.
Oh, well, this is cool.
I read that
next year, NASCAR
is reportedly launching
an electric racing series.
It's like regular racing,
except the winner pounds
a gallon of oatmilk.
Did you guys see this?
Tomorrow's Mega Millions jackpot
is up to $790 million.
-Oh.
-$790 million.
You could tell everyone
wants to win this.
Even the guy who calls
the numbers every night.
Listen to this.
-To win that jackpot, you must
match these five white balls,
plus that gold mega ball.
Here we go.
First. 60. Oh, my God.
Next, it's 66. Oh, my God.
Then it's 14. [ Laughs ]
Kurt! I'm quitting!
Then 40. [ Laughs ]
I always hated
your stupid face, Kurt!
And come on, 32...
Mother[bleep]!
-Yeah, sorry, alright.
-Kurt, I'm sorry
for what I said.
-Unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, this is going viral --
a contractor is being blamed
for an unusual problem
in one California town.
Take a look at this.
-A city contractor in California
painted the crookedest road
in the world.
The strange zigzag markings
are not what city officials
had in mind.
A massive do-over is on the way
to replace these odd squiggles
with new lane
markings done to code.
Yeah. This is why you
just don't tell city employees
to "just have fun with it."
Well, guys, this is fun.
Today is National
Aunt and Uncles Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I love my aunts and uncles.
They've taught me so much,
like the difference between
wine drunk and beer drunk.
Hey, everyone's
talking about this.
Tonight's Mega Millions jackpot
is one of the biggest ever,
at nearly $1 billion.
If you forgot to buy a ticket,
congrats, you just won $2.
Yep, by tonight,
some lucky person
is gonna gain
millions of dollars
and hundreds of new cousins.
"Hey, happy Aunt And Uncles Day.
Remember me?"
That's right --
nearly a billion dollars.
Yeah, that kind of
money's a lot of pressure.
I mean, if you win that,
next thing you know,
you're buying Twitter
and having an affair with
the founder of Google's wife,
you know?
It's just --
It's a slippery slope.
Let's get to some news
here, guys.
As he continues to
recover from COVID,
President Biden told reporters
he's sleeping so well
that his dog had to
wake him up yesterday morning.
[ Laughter ]
And reporters responded with
a very nervous laugh.
They're like...
[ Laughs lightly ]
You know that dog was
kind of freaking out like,
"Joe? Joe? Joe? Whew."
You can tell Biden was tired,
'cause he tapped the dog's head
and told him to come back
nine minutes later.
More news from The White House.
I read that
to fight climate change,
the Biden administration
has pledged
to plant 1 billion trees.
Yep. And just
for fun, they're planting them
in the middle of Trump's
golf course at Mar-a-Lago.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right in the middle.
Meanwhile, this morning,
Biden woke up from
his COVID fever like,
"Did I order a billion trees?"
I'm sorry. Uh, yeah? Tariq?
-Um, yeah, I had a question.
Well, are they planting
a billion seeds
or a billion trees?
Because there's a difference.
-You know what?
I don't really know.
[ Chuckles ] Yes, Tariq.
-If I had to guess,
I'd say they're planting seeds.
♪♪
-'Cause you gotta plant
the seeds to make the trees.
-And you gotta wet the seeds
to get the leaves.
-A billion trees
from a billion seeds.
-We'll be seeing green
from sea-to-sea.
-So much pollen,
can't help but sneeze.
-But that's okay,
it's fine by me.
-'Cause clean air
is what we want to see.
-To the birds and
the insects and the bumblebees.
-We'll be oh-so-happy
to enjoy that breeze.
-A billion trees
from a billion seeds?
I got one answer,
yes, please.
-♪ Seeds and trees ♪
♪ Planting the crops ♪
♪ Ready or not ♪
-"Seeds and Trees Mixtape,
2022."
[ Air horn blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is going on?
-Man.
I saw that -- Guys, today,
former President Trump returned
to Washington, D.C.,
for the first time
since leaving office.
Trump said, "Well,
since I'm still the president,
it only makes sense I stop by."
Switching gears, T-Mobile
has agreed to pay its customers
$350 million in a settlement
over a massive data breach.
We actually have
their lawyer on the line
to explain their settlement.
Yeah, sir, are you there?
-Hi, Jimmy.
Thank you for having me.
"Tonight Show"...to be here.
-Sorry? This is
a massive settlement here,
so how are you feeling?
-Well, now that...settlement...
completed...
try to relax...
raspberry custard...
nipples...pet hamster.
-I'm sorry. You're cutting out.
Can you say that again?
-Of course.
I was just saying now that
the settlement is completed,
I...go home...
raspberry custard...
nipples...pet hamster.
-Sorry. It's still a bit choppy.
It's not really making sense.
Can you switch to Wi-Fi?
-Uh, sure, Jimmy. How's this?
Can you hear me now?
-It's much better. Thank you.
-Great.
I was just saying, now that the
settlement is completed,
I want to relax.
I think I might go home
and smear raspberry custard
on my nipples and let my
pet hamster nibble on it
until it tickles.
That usually helps me calm down.
-Alright, good luck with that.
Thank you for joining us today.
The lawyer from...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know.
Hey, have you guys seen this?
There's an online movement of
people who want Instagram
to go back to being
a photo-sharing app
and are criticizing it
for trying to copy TikTok.
You know things
are bad when Instagram
is getting bullied on Instagram.
Hey, guys, get this.
A dating site for
anti-vaxxers called Unjected
had -- this is real -- had all
of its user data exposed online.
Yeah. But don't worry.
Everyone is doing their own
research on how to fix it.
Users' names, birthdays, e-mail
addresses, and home addresses
were exposed,
but on the plus side,
their data is one step closer
to herd immunity.
Hey, listen to this.
According to a new report,
the Chevy Silverado
is the most stolen vehicle
in the country.
-Ooh!
-And Chevy decided to use
this fact as a selling point
in their latest commercial.
Watch this.
-So, our Silverado is the
most stolen vehicle in America.
Well, maybe it's because of
our Duramax turbo-diesel engine.
Or maybe it's because of
our automatic emergency braking.
Or just maybe it's because
our doors don't lock,
there's no alarm system,
and you can start the truck
just by breathing
on the steering wheel.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
-Chevy Silverado --
apparently, they're free now.
-I saw that today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, I saw a house listing
that's getting a lot of
attention for
its strange design.
Check this thing out.
-An unusual property
in Pismo Beach, California,
is attracting
a lot of attention.
The listing on Zillow could be
a record for a tree house.
It is actually a house
built around a tree.
Asking price -- $3.8 million.
-It sounds like good idea until
you walk into the bathroom
and you see a squirrel
holding his nuts, you know?
-Hey! Whoa!
-Here's some good news.
Today, President Biden
officially ended
his quarantine after
testing negative for COVID.
Yeah, that's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now that he's got
a few weeks of immunity,
Biden's about to rage!
Ooh!
♪♪
"Jill, we're having dinner
at 7 o'clock tonight.
Oh, yeah."
Yeah, Biden beat COVID,
and, luckily,
COVID conceded gracefully.
Even though he tested negative,
not that much changes for Biden.
He still works from home,
avoids crowds,
and takes 20 pills a day.
That's right,
Biden is COVID-free.
He even gave a quick speech from
The White House Rose Garden,
and it sounds like
he's back to his old self.
Take a listen.
-Millions of Americans
have used Paxlavoid --
Paxlovid, excuse me.
Paxlovid.
[ Chuckles ]
I tell you what,
I think it's -- I used it.
[ Laughs ]
-Welcome back, Mr. President.
Welcome back.
Can we wrap it up?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some more news from
The White House.
The Biden administration
just launched a new website
designed to help Americans
facing extreme temperatures
called Heat.gov.
Yeah, the website is
still in the beta phase,
so they only have
one photo and one video.
Here's the photo. And...
And here's the video.
So, just stay cool.
That's all I can say is
stay cool, everybody.
Guys, yesterday,
former president Trump
gave a speech
in Washington, D.C.,
and he said pretty much
what you'd expect.
So instead of showing
the same clips
that you've seen
a million times,
it's time for another
installment of
"Trump With No Context."
Enjoy.
[ Fanfare ]
-I'd go up to LeBron James.
It doesn't matter.
I'd say, "LeBron, did you ever
have any desire to be a woman?"
[ Fanfare ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-Well, former vice president --
I have no --
-What?
-Former vice president
Mike Pence
has a new memoir coming out
in November,
and he just revealed that the
title is "So Help Me God."
But that wasn't the first title
that he came up with.
We actually got our hands on
some of the other ones
that he was considering.
So let's --
-Oh, here we go.
-What's up, Tariq?
-Let me guess.
You're going to list a bunch of
fake Mike Pence memoir titles.
-I mean, yeah,
that was the plan.
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
And then a little graphic
is going to pop up
for each one
so that the audience
can read the title
and then "laugh about it."
-Right, yeah.
Visuals often help sell a joke.
Yeah, they would love it. Yeah.
-Yeah, I know exactly
how this is going to go down.
See, first, a graphic
will pop up that says...
And then, under that, you'll
list, like, fake book titles,
something like...
-Yeah, yeah.
-Or...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's true.
-And then you'll try
some other ones like...
Or -- I don't know --
something like...
-Yeah.
-Or...
-Yeah, that's true.
-And then you're just going to
end it with something
a little controversial like...
-Yeah, yeah.
-Is that --
That's how this is gonna go?
-Yeah, yeah. You nailed it.
-Cool, 'cause it's a fun bit.
You should do it.
-We'll do it tomorrow.
Tariq Trotter, everybody.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Some business news.
I read that Chipotle is
about to raise their prices
for the second time this year.
[ Audience boos ]
At this point, they're becoming
the fast-food version
of Netflix.
Yeah, their prices
are getting crazy.
At Chipotle,
now E. coli is $2 extra.
Can you believe that?
Did you guys see this?
Once again, nobody hit last
night's Mega Millions jackpot,
and now the prize
has surged to over $1 billion.
Yep, winning this jackpot
is probably
the fastest way
to become a billionaire.
The other way is
being a trillionaire
who invests in Bitcoin.
Yeah.
Well, this is cool.
Apparently, here in the city,
they're about to expand
cell service and Wi-Fi
in the subway.
So if you're watching our show
on the train right now,
here are some
New York-subway-riding
tips for you.
Number one...
That usually helps, yeah.
Number two...
That usually works.
And, finally, number three...
There you have it.
There's a little tip
for you guys.
Thank you for watching the show
on the subway.
Well, get this.
According to a new survey,
when dinner is ready,
the majority of parents
text their kids
instead of yelling to them.
Yep, parents text their kids
when dinner is ready.
Yep, then the kids respond,
"Mom, that's not what
an eggplant emoji means.
Don't do that."
♪♪
-Eggplant.
-And, finally, a former
strip club in Wisconsin
has been turned into
a Christian Day school.
Yeah, it's going to be
weird on Parent-Teacher Day
when all the dads know
their way around the building.
Well, guys,
some big business news.
Today, JetBlue announced
they reached a deal
to buy Spirit Airlines.
-Ooh!
-Yes.
JetBlue and Spirit.
It's the
perfect marriage between
broken TVs and broken planes.
It's unbelievable.
It's -- That's right.
Spirit agreed to
a deal with JetBlue
and cancelled their merger
with Frontier Airlines.
Today, Frontier was like,
"Well, it's Spirit.
How did we not see
this cancellation coming?"
Some news from Washington.
President Biden
is celebrating a huge win
after Senator Joe Manchin
suddenly agreed
to support his
climate and economic bill,
meaning it will now
most likely pass.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a
huge victory for Biden.
In fact,
right after the announcement,
his approval rating
skyrocketed to 11%.
-Oh.
-That's right.
-Switching gears,
apparently, this year,
Hershey doesn't think that
they're going to be able to meet
the demand for Halloween.
In a related story,
Biden's approval rating
just fell back under 10%.
Did you guys see this?
In an effort to be
more eco-friendly,
Coca-Cola announced
that Sprite will no longer
be sold in green bottles.
Most Americans
heard and were like,
"Damn, that was the
only green thing in my diet."
That's right.
Everyone had the same reaction.
They're like, "Make the bottle
whatever color you want.
It's all getting filled with
vodka anyway, alright?
Oh!
-Ooh!
-Hey! Hey!
-Make a noise.
Fill it up.
-That's right.
Sprite's getting rid of
the green bottles
'cause they're not
environmentally friendly.
I guess that
explains this new ad I saw.
Watch this.
-Health-Ade Kombucha
is proud to announce
our new all-natural,
completely waste-free bottle...
Kevin's hands.
Yep, no bottle, no can,
just Kevin.
Find him and lap it up
out of his hands like a dog.
That's how it works now.
Health-Ade Kombucha --
it's in Kevin's hands now.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Today is
National Water Park Day.
-Hey!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There are so many great
water parks out there,
and I just saw this interesting
promo to celebrate them.
Take a look at this.
-Happy National Water Park Day,
a day that honors
all our country's amazing
water parks, like...
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm excited.
Well, everyone's
talking about this.
In just a few minutes,
Beyoncé is releasing
her new album, "Renaissance."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which means, tomorrow,
all banks and government
buildings will be closed.
Yeah.
Speaking of Beyoncé's new album,
it was actually
leaked yesterday,
and her fan base, the Beyhive,
is pretty upset about it.
-Yes, we are.
So rude.
Really made my blood boil.
-You're in the Beyhive?
-Uh, yeah.
Member since "Sasha Fierce."
What? You don't expect me
to love music or
appreciate a queen
wearing her crown?
-No, I just didn't know that
we were...
both members.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, this is cool.
MTV has added a category for
Best Metaverse Performance
to the VMAs.
Yeah.
Best Metaverse Performance.
There are so many great artists
who have performed
in the Metaverse this year,
so there's gonna be
some tough competition.
Yeah, check out this concert
Post Malone did
in the Metaverse.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
♪♪
-[ Robotic voice ] Hello.
I am going to do
singing of my song now.
Activate music.
♪♪
♪ Let's have fun time tonight ♪
♪ Baby, you are my wife ♪
♪ Hello ♪
-[ Squawking ]
-Thank you. I did the music.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Hey, I heard about
a man in Florida
who was arrested for a D.U.I.
at Walmart
after he crashed a motorized
scooter into the shelves.
Wait a second.
Walmart, drunk,
scooter crash, arrested.
Bingo! I got Florida bingo!
I got it! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Awesome.
And, finally, Fancy Feast is
opening up a pop-up restaurant
in New York City that will serve
cat-food-inspired dishes.
When you sit down,
the waiter is like,
"Sparkling, still,
or from the toilet?"